hello my name is lindsay costantini i am
currently an assistant professor
in the biological and biomedical
sciences department at north carolina
central university
today i'll be discussing some of my
research involving visualizing viral
replication of oncogenic human herpes
viruses
but before i get into the science i just
wanted to give a little bit of
background about
my experiences and what have led me to
develop a research program that
investigates these oncogenic viruses
so my doctoral work was conducted at
albert einstein college of medicine
i primarily did cell biology based
studies and utilized a lot of
lifestyle fluorescence microscopy
techniques i then went on to complete a
postdoctoral fellowship at the
university of north carolina at chapel
hill
there i moved more into the field of
virology and also
increased my abilities in microscopy
into electron microscopy
and now today in my lab at nc central i
combine these interests and cell
molecular biology to study the cell
molecular biology of oncogenic viruses
so for the purpose of today's talk i'm
going to focus on two major areas
the first being just an introduction
into oncogenic herpes virus dna
replication
our goal is to be able to characterize
the kshv
or their carposi sarcoma herpes virus
dna replication proteins
and how they interact with viral dna as
well as protein protein interactions
we also hope to investigate how
different cellular proteins that are
normally involved in the dna replication
processes
or transcriptional processes also may
interact with some of these viral
proteins in infected cells
and we primarily do this using a high
resolution electron microscopy based
approach
and this allows us to directly visualize
purified proteins and purified nucleic
acids
and we use transmission electron
microscopy along with
specialized sample preparation
techniques that i will highlight
throughout the tech
throughout the talk for the um the
different electron micrographs that are
featured
so in general viral infections are
estimated to cause between 15 to 20
of human cancers listed in this table
here
are a breakdown of dna viruses as well
as rna viruses that are recognized by
the who
to be ideologically responsible for
certain human cancers
i'm primarily interested in the family
of herpes viruses specifically carposi
sarcoma herpes
associated herpes virus which is also
known as herpesvirus 8.
a closely related viru herpes virus is
epstein-barr which is more commonly
known
it's more prevalent in populations but
there are other families of viruses that
also contain viruses that are known to
associate with
causing different human cancers and
they're also listed here
in terms of human herpes viruses there
are already eight
identified kshv happens to be the most
recently identified human herpes virus
they're broken down
into about three different into three
categories the alpha beta and gamma
sub families and herpes simplex the
alpha
versions um are probably more commonly
known herpes viruses so like
the viruses that are associated with
herpes simplex as well as the virus
that's called
associated with chickenpox or the
varicella zoster virus
those are examples of alpha herpes
viruses um
beta the probably the most well-known or
more commonly known is the sedomegovirus
cmv and then in terms of gamma viruses
which is really where our focus and my
lab focus
examines is the gamma family herpes
viruses and that like i said before
includes kshv as well as epstein-barr
so in terms of infection once
kshv infects a host
it's primarily going to infect
endothelial epithelial and b
cells those are the primary cell
tropisms and
in patients who are immunocompromised
the likelihood of potentially
developing kshv associated cancers is
much greater
and those associated cancers are known
to be carposy sarcoma
abbreviated ks or primary effusion
lymphoma and multicentric
castleman's disease and both of these
two other cancers are associated with b
cell proliferative cancers and like all
herpes viruses
once you are infected with kshv it's a
lifelong infection
and this is true for all of the herpes
viruses that i mentioned on the previous
slide
and this brings us to where we're
focusing on
is understanding that life cycle since
it is a lifelong infection
we want to understand the phases and how
the virus and cell
coexist and how the viral
infection remains persistent so in
general
herpes viruses have a basically a
biphasic life cycle so after primary
infection
the virus is going to establish latency
or dormancy
in primarily b cells in the human body
and this during this latency phase the
virus is able to
maintain its viral genome and then
during certain phases of
one's life or the infected individual's
life there is
reactivation and reactivation is that
transition from the dormant phase
back into the active phase and the
active phase or the lytic phase
is when new virus particles are produced
and in order for that to happen
you have to have four major steps that
are occurring right so the viral
proteins need to be produced the viral
genome needs to be replicated
these two components need to assemble
into new viruses and then eventually the
new
infectious virions need to be released
from the infected cell to then spread
to um other cell other cells to then
propagate
and ensure that persistent infection
the key step of the lytic viral
replication phase is what we're
interested in studying is that
viral dna replication part so within
that there are key components that we've
identified that are
required and necessary so on the kshb
genome
there are multiple lytic origins of
replication
um two are denoted as o
r lytic l and r and that just denotes a
left and right origin and we'll get more
into that
in some follow-up slides in addition to
the region of dna that act as the origin
or the initiation
site for where viral dna replication
begins
are a host of dna replication proteins
and kshv has been identified to have
seven required dna replication proteins
and they're listed here
and it has been shown in the literature
that these um
are necessary and essential for ksh
for the kshv genome to essentially um to
effectively replicate during the lytic
phase
so shown here is just a little bit more
of a focus
on the kshb genome so the genome
is a large double-stranded genome it's
between 165 and 175 kilobases
as you can see by the cartoon
representation below in this bar graph
this shady colored different bar graph
i've also highlighted the approximate
location of the two origins and you can
see
the left and the right are on opposites
in opposite ends of the genome
in the actual virions in the infectious
virus particles
the kshv genome is linear
double stranded dna however when the
virus transitions in infected cells to
the latent phase
the the viral genome goes through a
restructuring and becomes a circular
conformation
and that has to do with ensuring that
the viral
genome is able to be maintained in these
latent or dormant infections
and shown here is the first of many
electron micrographs that i'll be
sharing with you today
this is an example of a method that
allows us to visualize dna
and so what you can see in this image is
you can see the white spaghetti
spaghetti-like structures distributed
across the entire em grid
and then you can see white pumpkin
structures um in sporadic patterns
so those white pumpkin structures that
are a little bit more
3d and raised off of the em grid those
actually are um the remnants
of a kshv virion and what we've done is
we've artificially disrupted
the virus to basically allow the dna to
extrude out
and what you're seeing here is all those
spaghetti-like structures are in fact
the
viral gene vital genome mounted onto the
surface of an electron micro
an electron microscope grid
so as i've mentioned already we are
interested in the viral proteins and the
viral dna that come together that allow
the viral genome to be replicated
but in order to be able to do these
types of studies we need to have
all the all of the dna and protein
together in order to
combine them and allow us to do these
molecular resolution molecular studies
so we have a system that we're
developing that will allow us to
sub clone and express our viral proteins
of interest in a mammalian expression
system which you can then can purify the
vital proteins from
traditionally most viral purification
can be done from bacteria or
insect cells but we're hoping to really
move into a more mammalian system that
will allow us to ensure
a high level of protein activity in
addition we have a system already in
place that allows us to
sub clone and
our dnas of interest into vector
backbones and that will allow us to
amplify and then isolate
known sequences and known sizes of dna
with high regularity
so overall our big question is how do
the kshv dna replication proteins
organize on this viral
origin dna and so this is just again a
cartoon
schematic of an overall the linear
double stranded genome and now we're
just going to focus in on how some of
these proteins
interact with the origin of replication
dna
so i've just shown a cartoon
representation here of the five
viral dna replication proteins that we
already have in our lab
and we also possess both of the lytic
origin dna sequences
that we can regularly clone and digest
and then
utilize in our studies so our big
question is can we
visualize dna going from the closed
conformation to the open conformation
in addition can we also examine where do
the d
where on the dna do the proteins of
interest bind
how might these proteins interact with
other dna and other proteins
and is there a way that we can figure
out the order in which the proteins
assemble on this pre-initiation complex
the ultimate goal would be is if we can
identify novel activities of the kshv
or herpes virus dna replication proteins
that are unique
from our own dna replication machinery
we can then use those unique activities
for binding
um binding conformations and all those
types of information that we infer
to identify novel replication inhibitor
targets that can
specifically inhibit those activities
while
leaving the cellular machinery
[Music]
non-non-changed
so in general to create an in vitro case
hvdn replication system we utilize
specialized electron microscopy to
visualize
the purified kshv core dna proteins as
well as
dna and protein complexes we began work
on the four proteins listed here which
includes an origin binding protein a
processivity factor
a polymerase and a single strand and
binding protein but today i will be
focusing on some of the work that we've
been able to accomplish
looking at the origin binding protein or
50 also known as rta
as well as some conformational studies
where we've been beginning to examine
how
or 59 which is the process of defactor
assembles in vitro
so just to give a little bit more detail
so again using tem
we can look at protein dna interactions
in addition to that we can actually map
protein binding sites and we can map the
locations as well as frequencies
and this is a unique approach because we
already know the sequence of the origin
sequences
and therefore we can then correlate
position based on electron micrographs
with location and i will focus a little
bit on some subsequent slides about that
in addition one of the major advantages
that we
[Music]
identified using tem is that we are able
to better assess
heterogeneous populations and structures
so using more population-based
approaches where you take an average or
you might do a gel-based approach which
allows you to look at what is the most
prominent
species or interaction or binding site
our methods really do allow us to look
at the single cell level and really
identify
majority and minority different
heterogeneous complexes
just to give a little bit more
background into em we can use
multiple sampling approaches our sample
preparations
so you can use thin sectioning using an
ultra microtome which if you look at
panels a and b
that's an example so these are kshv
infected cells that we have
thin section and use tem to examine and
what you can see in a is you can get a
nice
ultra structure of an entire cell this
happens to be
be a b cell latently infected with kshv
in panel b it's a bit zoomed in and this
is actually the nucleus of an infected
cell and what we can see are these um
viral replication centers that are
forming and those are those punctate
structures
in addition to that some of the methods
that
were piloted in my postdoctoral lab we
can apply to look at protein dna
interactions and that includes metal
shadow casting
so if you go all the way to the other
side of the spectrum to the nanometer
scale in panel g
and h you can see individual proteins or
individual proteins binding to dna
and the contrast that metal shadow
casting provides really allows us to see
this
in-depth molecular detail at the
nanometer
scale in addition we also use a pretty
standard electron microscopy approach
called negative staining and that allows
us to visualize proteins viruses and
vesicles
and some representative examples are
shown in panel e and f
and again i'm using a transmission
electron microscope and i'm using
a digital camera to capture my images
so back to how we visualize the regions
of dna that we're interested in
again these are some representative em
micrographs this is using a tungsten
rotary shadow casting approach
this is looking at the right origin
which is approximately a 2.4 kb piece of
dna on the left side of your screen
labeled kshv origin dna we have just
mounted
the digested fragments of the origin
the right origin and mounted them onto
an em grid the background is that dark
color
the white spaghetti-like structures that
are on the surface
are the actual dna molecules and you can
see
they um they will be mounted onto the
grid and they sometimes have more of an
elongated shape sometimes they form
loops
and so all of that allows us to see how
potentially differences
in dna structure that can arise when we
look at different dna
protein interactions in addition because
we want to have a quantitative approach
we can also preferentially label since
we again know the sequence we can use a
schematic where
we are an approach where we use a biotin
labeled dntp that will preferentially
only label one end
of the origin sequence that we are
interested in looking at then we can
come in
and add streptavidin which will
preferentially bind and what you can see
on the right hand side of your slide is
an example of what a labeled
origin dna replication an origin dna
would look like
in which case the arrows are denoting
the streptavidin which would be bound to
the ctp that is integrated into
our origin dna so with that that allows
us to have directionality and i will
show you how that matters when we get
into the
analysis where we're looking at binding
site frequency and location
so a little bit more background about
the first protein that i'm going to talk
about today and that's
or 50. so again we're interested in
understanding how or 50
and the origin come together and
interact
in general or 50 is it's known
it's uh to bind to the origin of
replication it's also known to interact
with 459 which is the
polymerase processivity factor it's
shown to be essential for viral
application it is known to recruit the
entire dna replication protein complex
key to initiating viral dna replication
and it also has a role
in initiating different lytic gene
expression
so on the right side of your screen you
can see another representative electron
micrograph image
in which we have both 450 and the origin
the right origin we've done an in vitro
binding assay and then we've
gone through the steps of mounting the
dna and protein complexes on a grid and
used the tungsten rotary shadow casting
method to visualize or
provide additional contrast again the
background is going to be dark
and then you can see white globular
structures um
dotted around the entire background
those are proteins not bound to dna
and then what you can see in the middle
right side of the screen you can see
just a dna molecule with no proteins
found
and then you can denote where the arrows
are indicating that would be a location
where or 50 has been shown to be bound
to the origin dna sequence
so like i said we want to be able to
quantify this and we can
our goal is to be able to measure
frequency and map positions
traditionally a chip seek type approach
or a similar comparable approach could
be used to ascertain this type of
information however
those might not be as sensitive to
locations that are maybe less frequent
than others and so what we can do again
we have our schematic that will allow us
our protocol that allows us to
preferentially bind one of our ends of
our origin this in this case the right
origin with biotin then we come in and
we label with streptavidin
we then do a binding acid with our dna
and protein of
interest and then we take hundreds of
electron micrographs
and then we quantify that so what we can
do is then we can use our software
and we can trace and identify the length
of the dna so we can take full length
denoted by this gray
over um overlay then we can go back and
we can measure the distance between the
streptavidin
and the protein of interest in this case
450. we can also measure the distance
between the or 50 and the unlabeled end
of dna
we can also measure the distance between
the streptavidin to the far end of the
protein
as well as the far end of the protein to
the unlabeled end of origin
of the lytic dna that the
lytic origin that we're looking at and
together that we can do
a correlation with the sequence and we
can convert our nanometer measurements
to the base pair sequence
of the lytic origin and we can identify
where on the origin that protein is
bound so this is just a represent
example of one mapping one of these
sites and if we map
the position of this 450 molecule on
this molecule dna
it correlates to about a position 1900
base pair
within the la the right origin that
piece of dna
that we're looking at so we can do this
many times and we can quantify hundreds
of different molecules
and what we can then do is we can map
the frequency so
shown on the bottom of this panel you
see a gray bar with green purple and
blue
highlighted regions the purple regions
map to predicted or
or 50 binding sites the green a
region maps to previously published
known binding sites
that were identified using more
traditional approaches and the parts
that are highlighted b
and c are the regions that we have
identified using our approach
that seem to have high frequency of
binding within those regions
and you can again see the frequency and
frequency high
rate of frequency correlates with a
higher bar um
and so from these types of methods we're
able to really
examine different
um where the protein is binding and then
whether or not
we see higher prevalence in certain
locations
we can apply this same method to look at
cellular transcription factors so there
are predicted
um consensus c foss and c june sites
within
the origin right and left sequences
and what we can now do is as a proof of
principle we can incubate purified cfos
and c june
with our origin dna that has three
predicted
consensus sites and those again are
highlighted with those purple regions
the purple regions map to where we where
the
sequence would be located on the piece
of dna
the blue bars that i've highlighted
really just highlight the highest
percent of frequency for that region
that correlates with our analysis so
again the electron micro micrograph on
the left
shows you the dna structure as well as
the
globular protein bound to it and what we
hopefully
you can agree with us and see that the
highest frequency is at those predicted
sites
and this cfos see june consensus
sequence are extremely well studied and
well characterized
so we feel that this is another proof of
principle that will allow us to then
um extend our approach to look at
multiple viral proteins and how they
interact with viral dna
another advantage to our approach is not
only can we do positional information
and looking at the heterogeneity of
binding but we can also look at how that
protein the conformation so as shown
here these are just two representative
micrographs that are just showing again
or 50 bound to different
origin dna sequences and what you can
see if you just look by eye
is that there might be some size
difference between the globular proteins
associated with
the dna on the left panel versus the um
or 50 molecules associated in the right
panel
and so for our approach we can actually
use standard
proteins standard globular proteins so
things like con albumin and alcohol
dehydrogenase have a very standard
globular shape and we know their
molecular weight so we can use those to
compare to the proteins of interest
so or 50 has a molecular predicted
molecular weight of 75 kilodaltons which
will be
comparable to a con albumin molecule in
addition
alcohol dehydrogenase would be more
correlated with a dimer
which is about 150 kilodaltons in size
so on the top panels you can see the or
50 molecules bound to the dna
in the bottom panels on the left hand
side you'll see just con albumin
examined during using electron
microscopy and so you can see these
white globular
dots associated all throughout the grid
and we can quantify those and take the
areas of those and then on the right
side you can see the same type of
electron micro
micrograph with alcohol dehydrogenase
along the back
um the background which is that dark
color you can see these white punctate
structures that
are the alcohol dehydrogenase protein
so we can then capture a bunch of
electron micrographs and we can then
quantify the area
of each of these molecules so the ones
that we know to be barely regular and
globular
versus what we want to understand of
whether or not the or 50 molecule binds
is a monomer or a dimer
so from this analysis we can see and you
can see the spread of all the molecules
that we
quantify we've quantified streptavidin
connell conalbumin which would be most
likely an or 50 monomer
alcohol dehydrogenase which would
correlate with an or 50 dimer
you can see the spread of the different
or 50 molecules bind
bound to the left origin dna actually
more correlates strongly with the
alcohol dehydrogenase this is a
quantification
when we look by eye that is also
correlated that the size comparison is
more like
the size of an alcohol dehydrogenase
protein compared to
the con albumin we can also apply this
same technique
to cellular proteins and we also have a
truncated version
of the or 50 molecule and we can clearly
show that with the smaller protein we
can actually quantify that difference
and present it as an average area
so overall i've hopefully um given you a
little bit of insight into our approach
and the strength of our approach we've
been able to
identify not only the 450 predicted
binding sites but we believe that we've
identified some novel binding sites
we believe that the or 50 protein binds
primarily as a dimer
and then we believe that potentially
these multiple binding sites that we're
able to identify
could have potential
could be important in understanding the
different functions of or 50 whether
it's the transcriptional functions or
the replication protein functions
in addition we hope to understand more
about how the or 50 dimerization might
help
to promote recruitment of these other
proteins
that are required for the dna
replication
so i have a few more representative data
that will talk about the or 50 or the
processivity complex and some of the
initial analysis we've done
doing this so in this example you have a
electron micrograph a representative
electron micrograph of 450 alone so this
is just the protein
and this is examined using negative
staining and what you can see on the
micrograph on the left hand side of your
screen
is there's a couple different structures
on the top you see three string
three ring-like structures and those are
denoted by the arrowheads
in the lower right hand corner you can
see more of
a pedal-like or maybe four individual
proteins that are coming together to
form a complex
and in the lower left hand corner you
can see an arrow that's denoting
a potential or 59 monomer
so in terms of the functionality of or
50 it's known to bind
to our origin dna it's also known to
interact with orc9 which is the
polymerase which this is a processivity
factor so
that makes complete sense in that and
then in addition we know that it also
has a role and combined with 450.
so we so that's already previously known
so now later when we
after we do these individual individual
characterizations we can then move on to
look at
combinations of proteins using our
approaches
it is also known that there is a
predicted dimerization domain
so if we just examine or 50 using
traditional methods
we can use native gels and what we can
use is we can use bsa as a size
comparison it's a relatively similar
um size estimate for monomers dimers et
cetera
and so what we can see is that we can
identify bands that will correlate with
the or predicted or 59 monomer
potentially dimer and then we can see a
large band that most likely correlates
to an or 50 hexamer
which would be six of the proteins
coming together um and that nicely
correlates with the bsa
ladder that we're using as a protein
comparison
however this doesn't account for the
fact in that last slide with the em
micrograph i was able to show you that
we see two different conformations
and so we can see what we believe to be
these more like petal-like structures
which are
look to be composed of four individual
monomers coming together to form a
complex
in addition we can see more of these
ring-like structures where the
individual proteins are less defined we
can then apply
different quantifications and
measurements so we can actually measure
the entire
diameter of the complex to have an idea
of what the
um overall dimensions are we can also
examine
the dimensions of the internal pore so
it looks like there's a dark center
presumably um if it is a processivity
factor that potentially binds
as a clamp type mechanism you would you
would assume that there would be some
sort of dna threading
and so we were able to quantify this
using our em techniques and we were able
to identify
what that diameter could be
so using these approaches um we were
able to identify
some novel protein conformations
so or 59 the observations that we have
are consistent with
the homologous ebv protein which is
known to be
oligomeric um we believe that it's
forming these head-to-tail dimers
and they can be into tetrameric or
hexameric
structures and based on our measurements
we understand that the central pore
would be
um wide enough or large enough to
accommodate a double-stranded dna duplex
which has a diameter of roughly two
nanometers
so we believe that the or 59 based on
our preliminary studies is functioning
as a sliding clamp
which is consistent with some of the
other predicted structures from other
herpes viruses but there is no
overall consensus and we're really
hoping that some of our
high resolution approaches will allow us
to
investigate that further so again i just
want to
round out the seminar today with just
reiterating some of the advantages of
directly visualizing
proteins and dnas using em we can see
heterogeneous complexes
we can assess the oligomeric state and
dna architecture
i didn't show you today in our
presentation but for instance sometimes
different dna protein
different dna protein interactions will
induce
loop formations or replication bubbles
which again we can all see using these
techniques and specialized stating
approaches and not only can we take
these images but then we can take it a
step further and quantify the data in
terms of identifying
position dna position mapping as well as
looking at molecular comparisons to
understand
what type of oligo or oligomer we're
looking at
so in general our future goals would be
to really understand how this herpes dna
replication pre-initiation complex forms
so based on some of the data i presented
and some other data that i wasn't able
to share with you today
we believe that or 50 will initiate
binding as a dimer
this will likely allow some sort of dna
distortion or unwinding at the origin
which will promote
potentially the single stranded binding
protein to
bind to the open origin in addition we
know that or
50 or rta has the capacity to interact
with the processivity factor or 59 so we
predict that this will now
allow for interaction between the or 50
molecule with the
processivity factor and then that will
allow the recruitment of the dna
polymerase
to then allow the initiation complex to
ensue
so just with that again
my focus is really understanding the
viral dna replication
our lab also has projects that also
investigate how cellular stress
influences bowel reactivation
and based on some of our techniques that
i've highlighted we are also
eager to con conduct collaborative
projects that i think that would have
that would learn something or gain some
insights based on some of our approaches
so lastly i just want to acknowledge
those who have
aided in allowing me to get to where i
am today um
researchers and lab members and
collaborators at albert einstein college
of medicine as well as those individuals
at the university
of north carolina as well as the members
of my lab here and some current
collaborators
so thank you and i look forward to
receiving questions
in the follow-up sessions